MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This
is primarily a
question-and-answer show, so if
any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
MIHAI IONESCU: Hello, welcome
to another session of Google
Payments live.
My name is Mihai Ionescu.
And--
VISHAL KUMAR: Hi, guys,
I'm Vishal.
I'm a PM who works on
the Payments team.
And today I'll be talking to you
about one of the products
that I work on.
PENG YING: And I'm Peng.
MIHAI IONESCU: So, Vishal,
thank you for coming.
Today's topic is the Google
Merchant Center.
So what is the Merchant
Center?
VISHAL KUMAR: So in our payment
system, we have
several users.
A lot of our users sell products
to other users.
So what happens is that we have
to design an experience
for the merchants
who are actually
selling their products.
This is where they would go to
see what their orders look
like and do any order management
that they had to,
among other things.
It's basically the experience
that we create for merchants
transacting on our system.
MIHAI IONESCU: Perfect.
Who uses the Merchant Center?
What are the users?
VISHAL KUMAR: Well, we have,
actually, quite a few
different sets of users who
use the Merchant Center.
In the product that we used to
call Checkout, there are these
merchants who are basically
using Checkout out as a way
for users to pay for the goods
that they just bought.
So we have quite a large number
of merchants who are
using the system over there.
And since we've started in-app
payments, as you guys are
really familiar with, all the
developers who are selling
virtual goods or goods using the
in-apps payment API would
go to the Merchant Center
to look at their sales.
And we also have, like, Android
developers as another
segment that would use our APIs
and hence can go to the
Merchant Center to view
their orders.
MIHAI IONESCU: So very useful
for quite a few developers.
Can you talk a little bit about
the common use cases?
How would someone take advantage
of the functionality
offered by the Merchant
Center?
VISHAL KUMAR: Sure,
I would love to.
So by far, the most common use
case for merchants at the
Merchant Center is
order management.
Merchants log in to get an idea
of the sales that are
going on on our platform,
to actually look at the
individual orders, and to
perform any order management
functions such as charging the
order-- in the case of
physical goods--
or canceling the order, or
refunding the order in case of
a customer complaint.
This is also where they would
go and download reports.
Say, for example, I wanted
to look at how many
orders I sold yesterday.
I could go and get a report that
would give me a list of
all the orders that came through
the system yesterday.
I can also look out for
exception use cases.
So for example, if one of my
goods suddenly started getting
a high charge-back rate, this is
where I would go to try to
diagnose the issue, understand
if a particular country was
causing the problem or
whether I was seeing
this across all countries.
Another big use case is, of
course, once you've sold
products, you want to get
paid for the products.
So this is where you would go to
link the account up to your
bank account and look at the
payments as we push them to
your bank account and keep
track of your earnings.
MIHAI IONESCU: Thank you.
PENG YING: Cool.
Yeah, I have some questions
for you too.
VISHAL KUMAR: Sure.
PENG YING: I hear, I hear that
you're working on a new
iteration of the Merchant
Center.
The old one's been, I don't
know, started in 2006, 2007,
and it's about five years old.
And I think we've been
[INAUDIBLE] some feedback
about some of the requests from
developers, [INAUDIBLE]
developers.
I was wondering if you could go
through maybe a preview of
what we have to look
for in the future.
Some of the specific pieces of
feedback have been, like,
sign-up is really difficult,
especially entering in all of
these different pieces
of information.
And sometimes it doesn't
go through.
And sometimes it's buggy.
And if you're going
to address that.
That if I'm the digital goods
merchant, then I don't really
need shipping addresses and that
kind of stuff-- and maybe
a better UI.
Maybe a better tax page that's
more easily understandable and
shows me the tax I need to pay
for a specific state or
specific country.
And a few other features.
I mean, we've sent you the
feedback, so what do you have?
What do you have
to show for it?
What's the future of the
Merchant Center?
VISHAL KUMAR: So I'd love to
talk about that a little bit.
Just as Peng was mentioning,
the old Merchant Center is
several years old now,
which, in Google
years, is really old.
PENG YING: It's dinosaurs.
VISHAL KUMAR: In a way.
So what we are working on
right now is a brand-new
iteration of the Merchant
Center.
We've kind of incorporated a
lot of the new UX stylings
which you may have seen across
some of our other products.
And we're going to address,
specifically, some of the
feedback that Peng
was mentioning.
The idea is that this is going
to be a product that we will
make significant investments
over the next coming quarters.
And today what I'm showing you
is just sort of the first step
into improving that
experience.
We have a lot of different new
merchant functionality coming
out, and we're going to try to
make this experience richer
and better for our merchants.
So without spending a lot of
time, let me sort of walk you
through some of the things that
you will see coming up
very shortly, like in the
next couple of weeks.
PENG YING: Whoa, you're
prepared.
A little slide deck
to show us.
VISHAL KUMAR: Hey, you
know, I'm a PM.
It's what I do for
a living, right?
So as Peng was talking about,
one of the key pieces of
feedback that we've heard is,
basically, the fact that the
Merchant Center is basically
this slightly old UI.
One sec, it's kind of moving--
oh, did I push it
in play mode?
PENG YING: Yeah.
VISHAL KUMAR: Sorry, guys.
So the old Merchant Center had
this issue that it was
basically built targeted
towards physical goods.
So when an in-apps merchant
signed in, they would see all
these sort of settings for
shipping rates, did they ship
the product, charging for this
individual order, which
basically made no sense
in their context.
So one of the things that we
did was create two UIs--
one for a digital merchant, and
then we would then take
this UI and add physical sale
functionality into the UI.
So today, if you're an in-apps
developer and you come to this
page, all you will see
are your orders.
And you'll be able to
see how much you're
making for these orders.
You wont to have to worry about
things like shipping or
other things that probably
didn't make
sense in your context.
However, the system will be
intelligent enough in the
future that if you were selling
both digital and
physical goods, it would
appropriately show you the
right options based
on the order.
So what I'm showing you here
is the new look of the UI.
You can see that we've got
the new UX styling.
It's a lot cleaner, a lot
more white space.
We've also combined the order
status and the fulfillment
status into one icon.
And we're using the light box--
the kind of traffic
signal analogy.
So if you see a yellow, it means
that order is sort of in
pending state.
A green is an order that has
gone through successfully.
And a red-- and this is probably
what the merchants
want to look out for-- are
orders that have issues.
Basically, this would be
something like a buyer's card
got declined, or we had some
issue with the order because
of which we couldn't finish
processing it.
I just want to show you a few
more screens to give you a
sense of what the
UI looks like.
You can see, you know, it really
looks a lot better than
the old UI that we had
that was kind of
dated at this point.
We've improved the search
functionality quite
significantly, actually.
We've added a lot more indexes
in the back end.
And you can now search by a lot
of different strings that
you couldn't do earlier.
PENG YING: I think we should
be pretty good at search
[INAUDIBLE].
VISHAL KUMAR: It's true,
this is true.
This is just kind of going
down the UI list.
So it has a [INAUDIBLE]
of functionalities.
If you went over an order,
it would highlight it.
You could actually see what
order you were looking at.
You could click on it to get
a drill-down view where you
would see further details such
as-- what was the price in the
buyer's currency, in case that
was a different currency than
what the merchant specified;
what the different sort of
transaction fees that were
applied were, what their net
revenue was; potentially, an
exchange rate; and sort of the
sequence of events that
made up the order.
PENG YING: Is there any
additional information on this
page that wasn't in the
previous Merchant
Center order review?
VISHAL KUMAR: A few things
have been added.
So I think the way we display
currencies has been improved a
little bit.
But in this version, at least,
we're not gunning for massive
improvements.
We're just trying to make sure
that we have parity, and then
we will gradually improve the
experience over the next
couple of releases.
PENG YING: OK.
VISHAL KUMAR: So this is just
what a cancel would look like
if you tried to cancel
the order.
Again, just to kind of give you
guys a sense of the UI.
It's really a much more
beautiful, sort of
easier-flowing UI.
So let's talk about some other
pain points that Peng was
talking about.
PENG YING: Yeah, seems like you
have a full list there.
VISHAL KUMAR: I have
a few of them.
You know, Peng, Mihai have been
yelling at me for a while.
So I've been listening
to this.
Sign-up was definitely one of
the big things that I've heard
a few complaints about.
The form was really long.
It was easy to make mistakes.
There was a lot of extra
information that we were
asking for upfront.
So what we did in this release
was just clean up this form a
little bit.
We had to collect certain tax
information about the
merchants, which we were
attempting to do up front.
We've moved that towards
the back.
And what happens is that, during
your sign-up, we don't
ask you for this information
anymore.
However, when you try to link
a bank account and get
dispersed, you may get prompted
for this information,
depending on what our
lawyers tell us.
I will say that we still ask
for some of the information
about your business, and this is
basically to make it easier
for our customers to actually
contact you in
case there's an issue.
We'll been looking
into what further
improvements we can do.
I mean, our goal really
is to make the sign-up
as simple as possible.
PENG YING: Finally.
This is great.
VISHAL KUMAR: [LAUGH]
I see Peng's happy.
Let's see if we can
make him happier.
PENG YING: So another thing
is what about sandbox?
Because in sandbox,
[INAUDIBLE]
transactions are processed--
VISHAL KUMAR: Right.
PENG YING: So we can simplify
this further down.
So if I'm just a merchant, I
want to see what's going on, I
should just be able to click and
then you should just give
me credentials.
VISHAL KUMAR: Right, just
basically one-click
credentials.
So I've heard that feature
request from you guys.
We're actually working
on it right now.
And hopefully, in a next session
of GDL, I'll be happy
to tell you guys about what
we're doing to make the
sandbox implementation
really brain-dead
simple to sign up in.
PENG YING: Awesome.
VISHAL KUMAR: So kind of going
down this list, another common
complaint that I hear is
that it's very easy to
get sales tax wrong.
Merchants are often not aware
of how to put the
sales tax widget in.
And if any of you have tried
putting sales tax in, you'll
know that it was a pretty
painful wizard that we used to
have up there.
So what we're doing in this
release is just giving you
guys a really simple
tax widget.
We've broken it out into
a bunch of different
territories.
And for each territory, you
can set the tax rate.
Note that for US and Canada,
we actually accept taxes at
the province or the
state level.
Whereas for most other countries
it's a flat rate for
the country.
So I'm just going to quickly
give you a demo for what would
happen if I wanted to update,
say, the tax rate in Canada.
So I go ahead and hit Edit, and
it would give me all the
provinces in Canada.
If I checked one of these
boxes, I'd then get the
ability to, basically, put
in the tax rate for that
particular province.
And I'm done.
So it's really simple.
Go ahead.
PENG YING: Are we pulling
from our database?
Do we have, like, default tax
rates that we sync with, like,
[INAUDIBLE]
or tax people?
VISHAL KUMAR: We actually don't
have that in the back
end right now.
And it's almost sort of
intentional, because it's a
bit of a legal issue with us
keeping tax rates up to date,
and also because taxes really
depend on where the merchant
does business and where
they're registered.
It's kind of hard for us to
actually try to figure that
out automatically.
But we are looking at, in the
future, maybe connecting to a
tax service, so maybe allowing
them to provide, basically,
just the ability to tell us
where they're incorporated,
and we'd figure out the
taxes for them.
I just wanted to point out,
though, based on what you just
said, for the US, the merchant
has the option to select
something that we call TDS.
If he selects TDS, then,
basically, we automatically
calculate the tax rate for the
state and then charge the
taxes for them.
However, that service is only
available in the US right now.
PENG YING: So another question
that we often get is dealing
with the VAT, and how VAT is
different from sales tax.
VISHAL KUMAR: Right.
PENG YING: So how is VAT
handled in this?
Is it going to be--
would you specify the
price and then we
add on the VAT amount?
Or do you specify total price,
and specify VAT, and then we
just say, this total price
is inclusive of
this amount of VAT?
VISHAL KUMAR: So basically, what
they would do is give us
the VAT rate for the country
that they wanted to sell in.
And based on where the buyer
was, we would either show them
a tax-inclusive price or
a tax-exclusive price
automatically once we know where
the buyer's location,
that we would figure out the
tax-inclusive price based on
the tax rate that the
merchant gave us.
PENG YING: Cool.
VISHAL KUMAR: Yeah.
This is hopefully going to
address some of the feedback
that we've been getting.
So this is a big one.
You guys have probably run into
this issue a few times.
In our UI, you can export
the list of orders.
You basically give us two dates,
and we give you all the
orders that came out
in that date.
Until recently, we sort of had
a back-end limitation, where
we could only return about 5,000
rows from our database
at a given time.
This was a limit that we had
imposed based on some of the
performance metrics
of our system.
I'm glad to report that, in
the new version of the
Merchant Center, we will
hopefully be able to give you
as much data as you ask for.
Of course, if you ask us for a
few million rows, it might
take a little while.
But--
MIHAI IONESCU: That's
a big merchant.
VISHAL KUMAR: That's a-- you
know, and we have a few of
those in our system.
We do have a few of those
in our system.
But hopefully this will improve
things significantly
for you guys.
MIHAI IONESCU: So no limit?
VISHAL KUMAR: That's the plan.
MIHAI IONESCU: Theoretically.
PENG YING: Is this a regular
order report?
So there were two order
reports in the
old Checkout, or--
yeah, Checkout, Merchant
Center.
One of them was a regular
report, another one was the
report with extra details,
like billing address or
shipping address,
stuff like that.
Do you know which report
this one's pulling?
VISHAL KUMAR: It does have
fields for the billing address
and the shipping--
well, since it's digital,
it won't have shipping.
But it does have fields for
the billing address.
But basically, those are
returned only when, A, the
buyer allows it and we're
legally allowed to do so.
PENG YING: OK.
VISHAL KUMAR: So yeah, the API
kind of takes care of that.
And only in cases that we
can actually share that
information with the merchant
do we actually return it.
So let's talk a little bit about
some of the new features
that are coming in the
Merchant Center.
So one of the things that we've
heard from our merchants
is that they would like
better analytics.
They want to understand what's
going on in the system, who
they're selling to, and
where they're selling.
So in this first part of the
Merchant Center, I'm happy to
announce that we will have some
basic analytics baked
into the product.
This is just an idea of what
we think we can present.
And we will be adding a lot more
functionality over the
next few months to this page.
I also just wanted to call out
that one of my colleagues,
Mark, works a lot on this page
and will probably be talking
to you at some future session
about all the details and all
the information that
we can offer.
But just as a preview, what
you're seeing over here is
sort of your historical
sales over time.
You can select the time
range that you want.
And we'll give you some basic
information, such as, how many
buyers came through and bought
goods from you, how many
orders they placed, how many of
these buyers came back more
than once, what was the volume
of refunds and charge-backs
that you're seeing
on your system.
And then, where possible and
legally allowed, we will try
to display some demographic
information to you.
So examples might be-- what is
the age breakdown of the
customers who are buying your
goods, or are they male or are
they female.
Note that we don't always have
this data because it depends
on the user opting in and
sharing this data with us.
But where possible, we want to
give merchants more insight
into what's going on
on the system.
PENG YING: You should totally
tell me what I need to sell to
make the most money.
Tell me the hot products
that we're selling.
MIHAI IONESCU: Just
show [INAUDIBLE].
VISHAL KUMAR: You know, those
are exactly some of the ideas
that we're working on.
I don't want to steal Mark's
thunder, though, so I will let
him come and talk about all
the goods that he's got.
MIHAI IONESCU: I'm sure there
will be more to talk about.
VISHAL KUMAR: Yeah.
PENG YING: Well, so I think a
few merchants have already
integrated with Analytics.
And can you go into how this
differs from Google Analytics,
or how the systems co-exist?
VISHAL KUMAR: So I'll talk about
that really quickly.
Like I said, I don't want to
steal Mark's thunder, or he's
not going to be really
happy with me.
PENG YING: He's not here, so--
VISHAL KUMAR: Well, but he is
supposed to buy me a beer at
some point today, so you know.
And I want my beer.
So just coming back to what
Peng was asking, though,
Analytics is mostly based on
sort of mapping the funnels,
keeping track of users as they
go through the purchase
funnel, figuring out how many
users came through, what the
drop-off rate was, what
the [? paid ?]
rate was.
Analytics really don't have
insights into the orders
themselves.
The unique information we, as
the Checkouts or Google Wallet
platform possess, is we actually
see the orders.
We know where the users
are coming from.
We can track what currencies
they are actually purchasing
these goods in, how they're
paying for them, basically
information about the payment
system itself.
What we tried to focus on
as we were building this
Analytics page was data that
was unique to our system.
So what you'll see coming from
us over the next coming months
is tighter integration with
Analytics so that you can
track both the funnel as well
as your individual orders.
But in the Merchant Center
itself, the focus that you'll
see is towards the orders
that are being
placed in the system.
Again, I want to let Mark come
and talk a lot more in the
future about the stuff that
he's building over there.
PENG YING: Yeah, I'll definitely
have him on one of
these days.
VISHAL KUMAR: So a feature that
we announced at Google
I/O was subscriptions.
And I just wanted to show you
guys what you can do with
subscriptions in the new
Merchant Center.
If you start selling
subscriptions, which are
basically recurring payments
to users, you will see all
your subscriptions orders marked
with the Subscription
icon on the Orders page.
If you drill into them, you
will see that the Order
Details page has
a similar icon.
Now let's talk a little bit
about what is the extra
functionality that merchants
have on the
Order Details page.
So in the old page, all you
would do with an order is
essentially refund
or cancel it.
Now when you come to
subscriptions, you have a
series of orders tied to
a single subscription.
Another common operation that
you might want to perform is
canceling the entire
subscription.
So if the order is a
subscription order and you
chose to cancel it, you'll be
given an option of canceling
that individual order or
canceling the entire
subscription.
Canceling an individual order is
sort of like refunding the
customer for maybe one period,
be that a month, or a week, or
a year, maybe because he had
some problems with the
subscription or the content did
not refresh, or as just a
loyal customer kind of thing.
But if you wanted to ensure
that the customer was not
charged for the subscription in
the future, then you would
go ahead and cancel
the subscription.
Hopefully this comes
across in the UI.
These are one of the things that
we'd like users to try
out and give us feedback on.
I just also wanted to call out
that the Google cancellation
policy is--
when you cancel a subscription,
we don't
automatically refund the
unused portion of the
subscription.
We basically allow the customer
to have access to
that content till the
period runs out.
But we do not charge that
customer again.
Any questions about
this, guys?
PENG YING: Hmm, well, I mean,
it's much better because I
remember that merchants had a
lot of confusion trying to
cancel subscriptions.
They were like-- find the first
order of all the orders
and cancel that.
VISHAL KUMAR: It was definitely
something that, I
think, was not very intuitive.
And this is a feature
that I've heard a
lot of requests for.
So I'm sure the merchants are
looking forward to playing
around with this.
PENG YING: Is there
any way to view--
I'm not sure if this is useful
to merchants, but this is off
the top of my head.
Is there any way to view all
of the orders in, like, a
thread for subscriptions?
VISHAL KUMAR: So that's
a great feature, Peng.
We're actually going to
be developing that.
And you should see that coming
up in a couple of weeks.
I actually didn't throw it up in
these marks, because I was
kind of focusing on the things
that we'll be releasing in the
next coming weeks.
But this is a sort of a good
opportunity to let merchants
know that we've got a pretty
large and aggressive road map
for what we plan to do with
the Merchant Center.
We are trying to build a
one-stop shop for the
merchants to come in, and track
all their orders, and
track all their exchanges with
the Google Wallet at one spot.
PENG YING: Cool.
VISHAL KUMAR: So I wanted to
lastly talk a little bit about
some of the feedback that we've
heard around reconciling
orders to the disbursements
that merchants receive.
So what we're doing in this
release is actually just the
first step over there.
We've basically improved the
look and feel of the Payouts
page so that you can now get a
sense for what your earnings
were on a particular
day and what your
disbursements are like.
But what we really need
is a way to link an
order to the payment.
So the way the Google payment
system works is that we get a
series of orders from
the merchants.
At some point in time, we
raise an invoice, which
basically tells us how much
we owe the merchant.
And then we use the information
that the merchant
gave us to actually pay them.
What we're going to do is
introduce a page that will
allow you to link all the
orders that went into a
particular invoice.
And we will also tell you
how much we paid out
against each invoice.
Does that sound good?
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, that
sounds perfect.
It was very confusing.
VISHAL KUMAR: All right.
Yeah, so you know--
PENG YING: That's much easier
reconciliation.
VISHAL KUMAR: So that's kind
of everything that I just
wanted to touch on today.
Before I hand this back to Peng
and Mihai, though, we
really need your help to test
this new Merchant Center.
We're going to launch this
experience in the next couple
of weeks, and we want merchants
to sign up and play
with it and tell us what
they think about it.
So if you think this is
something you'd be interested
in doing, email me or email
us, rather, at this alias.
It's mc-feedback@google.com.
We monitor this alias.
We'll respond to any questions
that you send over here.
And if you're interested in
participating in our beta,
we'd love to hear what
you have to say.
Just before I leave, a
couple of caveats.
So currently, the new experience
will only work if
you're an in-app merchant.
If you're selling physical
goods or you're selling
Android apps, this experience
will not be available to you
for about another couple
of months.
And the other thing I would
say is that if you're a
customer who has been on our
system for a while, you will
not see your legacy
disbursements in this payout
format that I was just
talking about.
We will, however, link to a page
where you can see what
you've got disbursed
for in the past.
So a couple of caveats, but I
believe a big step forward.
And I'm really looking forward
to what you guys have to say
about the system.
PENG YING: So at a high level,
the main benefits are a really
easy-to-view overview page,
great subscription support, a
better order reports, or
unlimited order reports, and--
MIHAI IONESCU: Analytics?
PENG YING: Yeah, analytics.
So you can see--
VISHAL KUMAR: Great analytics.
Yeah, I mean I think, as Peng
was saying, we really improved
the user experience.
I think users will find the
UI to be fluid, a lot more
intuitive, easier to
find information.
There's a lot of in-context
help that will be
available to you.
There are tool tips that help
explain what's going on.
There are hovers so that
you understand
what the icons mean.
We spent a lot of time thinking
about how to make
this UX more desirable and
usable for merchants.
And then we've definitely
addressed some of the feedback--
specifically making the sign-up
a lot easier, giving
merchants analytics so they
have an insight into what
they're selling, giving
subscription support, which
has been a pretty common ask
from a lot of our merchants.
And we'll also be doing some
additional work around
addressing some of
the feedback that
Peng was talking about.
MIHAI IONESCU: So
quick question.
You said this is only available
for in-app merchants
in the near future.
What happens when a merchant
sells both physical and
digital goods?
VISHAL KUMAR: Right, so that's
a great question, Mihai.
In the first launch we won't
be able to support those
merchants on our new platform.
However, like I said, this is
just the way we've decided the
roadmap should work, because
we have to go and work with
each team to make sure
that the new
experience works for them.
So every week, we're trying to
get more and more of those
merchants onto our platform.
And basically, in a couple of
quarters I expect everybody
will be on this new
experience.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool.
VISHAL KUMAR: Yeah.
MIHAI IONESCU: Well, thank
you very much, Vishal.
I hope everyone enjoyed
the new preview of
the Merchant Center.
And quick reminder, if you
want to participate in
beta-testing the new Merchant
Center, send us a message to
mc-feedback@google.com and
we'll respond to you.
And we'll tell you how
you can test it.
Great, so we have a
few more minutes
to answer some questions.
Want to stick around
for questions?
VISHAL KUMAR: Sure.
MIHAI IONESCU: Thank you.
So let's see here.
We have a few people who
submitted questions on our
moderator page.
The first question is about
payment support in different
geographies.
What is the timeline for opening
up payments in other
geographies, specifically
France, India,
other European countries?
It's not clear if this refers to
in-app payments or Android.
PENG YING: Or Checkout.
MIHAI IONESCU: Or Checkout.
But let's assume it
refers to digital
payments or in-app payments.
France, it's supported on both
Android and in-app payments.
India, it's not supported
on either.
To give you a context, we offer
in-app payment support
in 31 countries on Android and
18 countries on digital goods
payments for the web.
We are adding new countries
all the time.
It is a laborious process,
not from a
technical point of view.
That is the easy part.
But we have to follow the legal
requirements for money
transfer in each one
of those countries.
So for some countries, it's
taking longer than others.
But we have been adding new
countries at a very nice pace.
Usually, new countries are added
to Android, and then
they shortly follow on
in-app payments.
So keep an eye on the
announcements, new
announcements from us.
We will be adding
new countries.
And I think the next couple
of questions--
PENG YING: Vishal, do you have
any more insight into
expanding internationally?
VISHAL KUMAR: No, unfortunately
not.
PENG YING: You're a
product manager.
I thought you guys were supposed
to know everything,
have insights group.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, the next
couple of questions are also
asking about the ETAs on
launching payment support in
new countries.
And as I said, we'll
keep you posted.
PENG YING: Rules and
regulations.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
And then we have a
question about--
this is in-app payments
for the web.
Is there a way to remove the
pop-up when the user first
initiates an in-app payment
transaction?
So the pop-up you're seeing when
you're first trying to
make a payment is needed
to log you in securely.
So it's a security feature.
If you're logged in, then you
won't see the pop-up.
We're looking at ways to
minimize that impact and find
a way to have you perform
the transaction
entirely within the page.
So we're working on that.
Stay tuned.
PENG YING: And something
about-- do you know?
I think it's something about
risk-based authentication
instead of just regular
authentication.
MIHAI IONESCU: There are ways to
minimize the impact of that
and make it a better
user experience.
But at the same time, we're
very careful about not
affecting your security
and identity.
PENG YING: Of course.
How about that, you have any
insight into that either?
VISHAL KUMAR: Clearly, I'm the
one who's supposed to have
insight into everything, huh?
PENG YING: Just focus on the
Merchant Center, man.
All right.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK, well--
PENG YING: We don't have
any more questions?
MIHAI IONESCU: We don't
have any more
questions for this week.
And we're out of time,
so we'll see
you at our next session.
PENG YING: Well, in two
weeks we have a
great session for you.
We're inviting the product
manager for Google Wallet.
So if you have any
Wallet-related questions, when
we put up the next session,
ask them in the moderator.
And with that, I think
we're done.
MIHAI IONESCU: Thank you.
VISHAL KUMAR: Thanks, guys.
MIHAI IONESCU: Bye.
PENG YING: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]